And now it's the old scout master.
You know why scout masters make lousy timekeepers.
I haven't met one yet who knows how long a minute is-
Yeah, including me.
Well, this is podcast number 66..
Hey, welcome back to the scout master podcast.
This is Clark Green.
Well, let's see. here
We're going to get all the emails and comments and reviews that have come in in the past week.
Let's go first to iTunes.
Todd Grady left a nice rating on iTunes where he said: scout master Clark Green shares his years of experience with the BSA in a concise, informative and fun format.
Wow, thanks, Todd.
Always nice to get some kind words.
Rob wrote in to say the new website is awesome.
Thank you very much.
It's at scoutmastercgcom-
Scoutmastercgcom.
Still a lot of stuff to get online there and some plans for the future,
So keep an eye on it.
Tom Heading, who is in troop 406 in Kashocton, Ohio-
I hope I said Kashocton properly. Tom
Says this. I've been involved in scouting since grade school in the 70s and love the insights you share.
By the way, I'm putting together some scout songs to play before our next court of honor
And I'm looking for all time favorite Boy Scout and the song from Switzerland.
I'm having a hard time finding them on iTunes.
Well, Tom, it's pretty simple.
What you need to do is go to any one of the posts that contains a podcast and you'll see a little Amazon widget
At the bottom of that post and that will point you to the different music that is used on the podcast,
And you can go ahead and go to Amazon and buy the MP3 version of that song right there.
So that helps support the people who make the music, and it helps me too.
So I really appreciate it and thanks for the kind words, Tom.
Steve Jensen is a scout master in Troop 228 in Santa Clarita, California,
And Steve wrote to say: you have no idea how helpful your podcast is.
It's taught me how to fish by driving home some basic principles.
I can't tell you how many seemingly difficult problems I've solved by just reading the requirements again
or going back to what scouting is all about.
I'm coming up on my first anniversary as a scout master
and I can honestly say I couldn't have done it without your help.
Your podcasts have done a lot more than just giving me a bunch of responses to canned situations.
They've given me a foundation and a basic set of principles
so I can come up with my own answers with confidence.
The results are obvious. We just picked up 22 new weeblos, a 50% increase in the size of our troop,
And our first two campouts have been the best I've ever been on.
It's all about following the program. Thank you,
Wow, Steve, that is fantastic. That is really fantastic.
I don't think you're listening to the podcast as responsible for getting 22 new weeblos
or as to blame for you getting 22 new weeblos.
Hey, folks, imagine that You go to a scout meeting and there's 22 new weeblos there.
Wow, that's intense.
But, Steve, seriously, thank you for the very kind words
and I'm glad that you're finding the podcast useful.
Bill McFarlane wrote in. he said
I was filling out a NYLT, that's National Youth Leadership Training Form- this morning
And I ran across something I had never seen before,
or if I had seen it before, it just never clicked with me.
The program is an adult-led, boy-run troop model.
Quote unquote.
What is an adult-led boy-run troop?
I always thought the model troop was boy-led and boy-run.
Wow, Bill, I had never seen that statement either,
Mostly because we don't really utilize the NYLT thing,
but that's a very interesting question.
Maybe the adults lead and the boys run,
I don't know,
It might just be an uncomfortably phrased sentence.
Maybe it should have read: adult-mentored and coached
and boy-led and run.
But yeah, sharp eye Bill.
Maybe somebody else out there has something to contribute
in answering that question
and you can email me at scoutmastercg at Verizonnet.
Scoutmastercg at Verizonnet.
So the Scoutmaster newsletter went out last week
and the newsletter is an email newsletter
that goes out once a month
and it's usually a bunch of resources
around a scouting theme.
It's a little digest of the blog and the podcast.
This month the theme is campfires and cooking.
It's one of my favorite things to do.
I included some of my favorite resources in there
and I included some of my favorite recipes as well.
I must say, with all modesty,
I am a pretty good campfire cook.
Yeah, I really enjoy doing that.
It's one of my favorite things to do
And it's a great giveaway. this month too.
Usually we are able to include a giveaway
from one of our affiliate sponsors
And this month it's going to be from the folks at Little Bug,
And they manufacture two different wood-burning stoves-
a senior and a junior-
And we just had a review about these stoves
on at scoutmastercgcom.
I've used them for years.
I think they're a great alternative
to either liquid fuel or, you know,
canisterized fuel stoves.
I think they're a lot better for the environment as well.
They're pretty lightweight,
They're pretty easy to use
and they just seem to be totally indestructible.
I recommend them highly.
And to qualify for the giveaway,
you need to be a subscriber to the newsletter
And then you need to go ahead
and answer a trivia question
And then we're going to do a random draw
from all the people who provide
the correct answer to the trivia question.
So go to scoutmastercgcom,
hit the subscribe link
and subscribe to the newsletter
And then you can get away in.
You can get away, Nope,
You can get in on the giveaway.
In this podcast
I'm going to answer a question about
Scoutmaster Eagle Conferences
after scoutmastership, in seven minutes or less.
And then we had a great response
to the questions that we asked
in our last podcast,
podcast number 65.
So we'll go and look at those responses
after scoutmastership in seven minutes or less,
And I think that's probably enough to do
in any podcast, wouldn't you say?
That's what I would say.
So let's get started.
Scoutmaster ship in seven minutes
or less.
Will Hensman,
He's a scoutmaster,
Scoutmaster Troop 777.
And he wrote in to ask this question.
He said
the discussion in podcast 63
on scoutmaster conferences
was very helpful and insightful.
I have my first
Eagle conference as a scoutmaster.
Do you have any suggestions
on how I can encourage
my Eagle candidate to prepare
for his border review?
I think he's truly a great candidate
for Eagle.
I just want to make sure I do my part
for him as a scoutmaster.
Well, Will, congratulations.
It's always a great moment
when you have somebody
who's completed all the work they need
for Eagle
and is ready to sit down
with you at a scoutmaster conference.
It's a great moment
and a great relief
in a lot of cases,
especially if they are 18,
11 months, two weeks
and seven days
or three days or whatever you know.
Here's what I do.
First of all,
my Eagle scoutmaster conferences
are not very formal
and they're pretty brief,
And here's the reason why
Most of the time I've been
in a pretty continuous dialogue
with a scout who is getting ready
to go to an Eagle border review.
He's been working on a project.
He's been
has had at minimum
10 months of a leadership position in the Troop,
So we've had
plenty of opportunity
to talk back and forth,
And so the first thing I will do
is I will reassure him
that he's a quality guy
that he did all the work that he needed to do
and that he should be very pleased
with what he has done.
I'll give him an encapsulated evaluation,
My encapsulated evaluation
of him as a leader,
which will typically be: you know,
you're a very capable leader,
You're very well.
I remember several instances where
it got difficult for you,
but you rose to the challenge
and you should be very satisfied.
So putting him at ease
is a pretty important thing.
And then, talking a little bit
about the border review,
it's much like all the other
boards of review that you've had.
There'll be some more people there.
They'll be asking more questions
than usual
And they will be evaluating
your Eagle project- and you know
it's quite a big deal-
recommending whether or not
you should become an Eagle Scout.
I have no doubt in my mind
that they will recommend you
become an Eagle Scout.
But let's prepare a little bit
for the types of questions
you're going to be asked.
Now, what kinds of questions
do you imagine they're going to ask you?
And if I met with you know,
kind of a blank stare.
we'll start teasing that out a little bit
by this method of socratic questioning,
if you want to put a fancy name to it,
which is basically just, you know,
asking questions to help people
hone their thinking
and to help them be on their feet
in a conversation.
It also helps them be unexpected
and be able to be flexible
in commanding the subject
that they're working with
and being able to answer questions
directed to them.
So I will get kind of pushy
with my questions
And my scouts by this time
have learned to understand
that this is a little game that we play,
that I'm not trying to be mean
or judgmental
or I'm not disappointed in them
in some way,
But I ask these hard questions
because it helps them think.
it helps them think forward
and helps them prepare
and also should help them discover
any places where they are unprepared
or where they're a little weak
in their thinking or knowledge.
So it's a bit of a game.
So tell me how your project
qualifies to be considered
a fulfillment of the requirement
for Eagle
And once in a while
I'll get a blank stare back.
I'll say, well, tell me what the
requirement for Eagle is.
so far as the project is concerned,
I'll say, well,
open the Scout Handbook there,
read it.
Okay, now defend your project
based on that requirement.
Tell me what you did as a leader.
Tell me why you think that
that experience should fulfill
the requirement for Eagle.
so far as leadership is concerned,
What were your most difficult decisions?
What was the most difficult time
you had as a leader?
What do you figure you got really good?
How do you figure you contributed to your troop?
What were your best achievements
as a leader in your opinion?
Now, why was that a great achievement
Or why was that a difficult time?
And, like I said, I'm kind of pushy
And then I can also let them
turn the tables on me
and ask me difficult questions
and kind of push me around it.
Like I say, if you work it right,
it's kind of a game that you play
with your Scouts
And you want them to push back,
You want them to defend themselves
and their ideas,
And that's, you know,
the method of Socratic Questioning.
That's what really makes it work.
So Will. I hope that helps you a little bit.
Once again, congratulations,
And I would love to hear from any of you
who have other input into
what should be discussed
or how to conduct a Scout Masters conference
with an Eagle candidate.
So do get in touch.
Hi, I'm Kevin Callan
And I'm listening to Scouts Master iPod.
No, I can't.
What is it called again?
Hi, I'm Kevin Callan, the happy camper,
And you're listening to the Scouts Master podcast.
Beautiful, beautiful.
Write me a letter,
Send it my name.
Email- that is folks.
I'm Kevin Callan,
Email. that is folks.
And here's an answer to one of your emails.
In podcast number 65,
I turn the tables on you
and I asked you four different questions
And I received a whole bunch of answers.
I've weeded through them a little bit
and I'm going to give you some
ones that I selected that sounded really good
And I'm going to answer three of those questions.
One of the questions was about
high adventure opportunities
in the central part of the United States,
And those answers are going to show up
online as posts in the
High Adventure Resources area
of ScoutsMasterCGcom,
So be looking for those there.
And we're going to answer the other three questions
right here right now.
The first one that we came up with
was: what do you do when a ScoutsMaster is retiring
but he doesn't really leave
And you know he's causing problems
and he's interfering with the present ScoutsMaster?
There were two basic
strings of thought in most of the answers
I received on this.
One was the nice guy way
and one was the old warhorse way.
Now, I think both of them are perfectly valid,
and I'm going to start with Larry Geiger,
who's in Cocoa Beach, Florida.
There's a ScoutsMaster there
And this is his second go round as a ScoutsMaster.
Larry was a ScoutsMaster for another troop
in another place
and then became a ScoutsMaster again.
And Larry has this to say:
He says: you really only have two options,
and the first one is to get rid of them.
And Larry, I wholeheartedly agree.
Larry's an old warhorse, and so am I,
In the best sense of the term, I hope
In the best sense of the term.
You want to be as nice as possible,
You want to be kind and considerate
and a good person,
But sometimes
volunteers need to be fired.
I'm saying it.
I am saying it.
Sometimes they need to go,
And to do that, you get the
Chartered Organization representative
and the committee chairman
and you sit down and you talk
and you make a move
and you get it done
and you get rid of the problem.
Sometimes that's the only solution.
It's extreme,
but I'm sharing it with you because
if you are presently finding yourself
in this situation,
that may be your alternative
and that may be what you need to do,
Without going into a broad
explanation and detail
of exactly how this process
happens and
the different issues involved in it.
let's just know
that that is one alternative.
If you need
some help with a situation like this,
get in touch.
Do what I can.
The second one was:
I'll go to Larry's second answer
because it was backed up
by several others.
Larry said work with the person
and he pointed this out.
he says a troop can only have
one scout master and only one.
I can imagine two committee chairs,
maybe splitting up some of the responsibility
of the leaders.
The scouts,
the boy leaders
and the other adults involved with the troop
have to know who has the last word on some things
and you need one scout master.
Larry goes on to say this.
he says: when I retired
from being scout master of my first troop,
I joined the committee.
I helped out a little with Eagles
and I went on a couple
of backpacking trips.
they went on a 50 miler every other year
with that for about six years.
but that's about it
and in retrospect that might have been too much.
Larry found a place.
having been the scout master before,
having understood the program,
found a way to get out of the way. but still help.
Steve Janssen,
he's a scout master too,
from troop 228 in Santa Clarita, California.
Steve was
on the nice guy side of things
but
he still understood that this could be a problem
and he suggested
the same thing that Larry did.
there may be another position,
there may be a way for them to still
remain and help out the troop.
there's also Bill McFarlane
who is up in Pittsfield, Massachusetts.
scout master
troop 8 suggested that
unexperienced scout master would be a valuable person
to have at the district level as a commissioner.
but going back to what Steve had to say,
he said I think it's good to have
the person as a mentor,
assertive,
listen to their advice and say: well,
here's what I'm going to do. anyway,
I'm not really asking for your approval
and I'm going to move forward.
and the old scout master needs
to understand that
he may see his job as filling a vacuum
and
if you don't let that vacuum exist in the first place,
you won't have the problem.
I think those are some pretty good answers
that should help define a couple of alternatives
and just to review
one is: hey, sometimes
you got a clean house
and you got to get
an interfering volunteer out of the way,
and there's ways to make that happen.
that's one alternative.
the second one is making sure that they have a responsibility,
that it's
clearly understood that that's their responsibility
and that they have
retired from other responsibilities
and being assertive about it.
one of the ways Steve
puts it is:
you need to let them know
that they made a real difference
and their experience is still valued,
and then to use their advice
and their counsel,
but to make it clear that it's now your responsibility.
thanks, guys, for helping out with that.
the second question:
I'm not going to tell you where the answers come from,
and the reason is it's a little sensitive.
the second question is:
how do you address a scout
who gets in trouble outside of scouts?
here's a couple possible scenarios:
he gets stopped by the police because he's involved
in some kind of a physical altercation
and maybe charges
stem from that.
maybe he is
gets a traffic violation.
maybe he has some kind of weapons violation.
maybe he gets in trouble at school
for any one of a hundred reasons
and ends up getting himself
suspended or even expelled.
what kind of notice does the troop
need to take of it?
how do you deal with it
and what happens
to the scout?
everyone who answered the question agreed that
there's no universal way to handle this.
it all depends on what the incident was
and that the decision point
came down to: is this
a clear and present danger
to any other scouts?
so if a boy gets a traffic violation
for speeding,
not necessarily a clear and present danger
to any other scouts,
if he's having trouble at school,
getting suspended for grades or something like that,
you know,
and that's one thing.
if it's a violent problem,
if it's a weapons violation,
if it's a drug violation,
there was a pretty much agreement
that this has to be looked at very seriously,
that it might involve
asking the scout
to step away from scouting
for a period of time.
I'm going to give you advice based on my experience
and based on the answers I got,
and that is
is that none of us-
unless you're a professional
and you're volunteering as a scout leader,
none of us are law enforcement officers
or lawyers or judges,
and we have an excellent law
enforcement system,
we have a great court system
and we have ways for these things to get sorted out,
and
I think it's very important,
before we make
any long-term decisions,
to let these things come to resolution.
I did have a scout
who had a weapons violation
and it resulted
in some charges.
it resulted in a real mess for him.
it was a very bad scene,
but realizing that I'm not a professional
investigator, policeman,
I'm not a lawyer,
I'm not a professional law
enforcement person,
what we had to decide to do was
to let the processes outside of scouting
come to a place
and come to a conclusion
before we were going to take any long-term action,
since
the charges
were a clear and present danger to other scouts.
if they proved to be true,
we had to get in touch with his folks
and say: look,
the nature of the charges are such
that we're going to have to ask him to step away
until they're resolved.
this isn't a punishment,
we're not trying to
be even more miserable,
but it's our duty
to our scouts and families
to take this step.
it was not a happy day for me,
not a happy day at all,
but
that's unfortunately what has to happen
sometimes.
I do want to give credit for this answer to Steve Jensen,
because
I think it's just general advice
and Steve wasn't relating
to me any specific
or anything like that.
but he said: at this point
the boy's entire world is likely to have crashed around him,
he's suspended from school
or he's in trouble and his family is likely very angry
and may be punishing him too,
and the troop doesn't necessarily have to join in.
we need to remind him about the responsibilities
he accepts each time he states
the scout oath of law.
we need to tell him
we expect him to meet those responsibilities
and then we need to believe in him.
this is probably a critical juncture
in that boy's life.
which direction is he going to go?
is he going to continue on a downward spiral
or is he going to get back on track?
there's likely enough punishment being doled out
to convince the boy he's done something wrong.
the troop
could be a safe haven,
a place where people believe in him
and just want him to do better.
Steve, that's excellently said
and I wanted to make sure you were tied to that statement.
that's just
really really good advice,
and there are any number of incidents
where this is going to be the advice you want to take,
where you want to back the child up.
he is a child.
we do have a juvenile justice system
that is different from the adult justice system
because it understands that there are different levels
of responsibility
in people in their developmental years.
I had a response
from another scout master.
he said some time ago a scout from my troop
was at school
after hours with a group of students
and he got in trouble.
the school handled the issue.
it came to my attention
and he and I sat down and discussed it.
since the school did not press charges
and the scout
abided by the school's decision regarding punishment,
I felt that there wasn't really any need
for us to take further action
than the discussion the scout and I had
as to what to tell the parents of the other scouts.
I directed them to contact
the scout directly
if they wanted any more information.
so that was a very good way of handling that.
here's what you did.
tell me about it.
do you think the punishment that you received is fair?
okay,
so now we're both on board.
we both understand what happened.
how are we going to take care of this in the future?
can you be trusted?
are we going to have any problems
within the confines of a scout troop?
the boys are going to talk to the boys
and the parents are going to find out
and they're going to want to know what's going on.
well,
if you really want to know what's going on,
go ahead and call their parents.
I'm not going to tell you anything.
I talked to the boy.
I'm sure that there's no present danger to your son
and if you think you need to know
the details of this,
call the boys parents.
I think that's excellent advice.
what do we tell parents? well, we tell the parents
that we're on the scout's side,
we're on his life and we need to be there for them.
we're not going to send him away,
that it's not a health and safety issue
and we're not just shrugging it off,
as boys will be boys,
or that there's no big deal.
but we feel that it's important for somebody
to stand behind him and we're going to stand behind him.
he knows he made a mistake
and it doesn't necessarily mean it's the end of everything
in his life.
so some very good answers to that from several people
and, like I said,
I'm going to keep most of that
just because of the sensitivity of the issue,
as I will with
another kind of sensitive issue,
and that issue is
what happens when you have a little flame war
in your troop
over the email.
yes, the email,
email is a wonderful thing until people start arguing
back and forth on it.
and people argue over email
with a great deal more vitriol
than they would ever argue in person.
I can't associate some of the people who answered
some of their answers
because they're just good general answers.
Larry Geiger said
you really have to try and ignore
people who do this.
the best way to avoid it
is to run all communication through one account
with a blind distribution list.
that way, if the reply comes back,
the troop leadership can deal with it.
by all means try to restrict having things distributed
to someone
so that they can just hit reply to all
and start a flame war.
the way that your emails are set up
is important.
if you don't understand the technicality of that,
one of the boys in the troop
probably does,
or one of the adults involved
with the committee will be able to get that set up.
but yeah, sending out
to a general distribution list
in which all the emails are
included
in the sent to part
of the email, very bad idea.
very bad idea because now
everybody who received the email
can just hit reply all
and then
the cat's out of the bag and
boy oh boy.
then you have a real mess.
anonymous
responder said this. I've had a lot of experience
with this one. unfortunately,
our chartered organization
recently put a stop
to a flame war
by just
going back and answering
the original question
and laid out the basic principles.
here's why we're here
and based on that,
here is the answer.
he did it in a way that wasn't preachy,
scolding or condescending,
just a statement of fact.
he didn't include the other emails in the chain.
he didn't address any of the sniping
or the other pettiness. they expressed
just simple, calm,
quiet, dignified
responses.
that ended the discussion
and I think everyone else went from being angry
to being ashamed as they realized just how petty
and silly they were being.
Bill McFarland- he answered one of the other questions
before. he said: my best suggestion is to
have a sit down meeting,
having anybody who's been
involved with the online
mess sit down
and talk. I definitely agree with Bill there
that any emails you send out
to your troop are informational,
not editorial. informational,
not editorial. you get the difference there.
any comment on people's actions
or thoughts, or especially
if that comment can
be read in any way
to be a criticism- if
someone needs to be criticized
or otherwise needs their actions
or words questioned, that needs
to be done in person,
not by an email.
let's go back over the whole email biz.
first of all, you can avoid
the flame wars
in two different ways.
one is to assure that the way
you're distributing emails doesn't allow
people to reply to all
and just send it back to the list,
and that's very, very important.
second way to avoid it
is to make sure
that emails are informational,
not editorial,
and that if there
is a problem that needs to be resolved,
it's never addressed in an email.
it's done in person.
how do you kill a flame war once it begins?
well, a calm, dignified, wise response
from somebody in authority,
basically telling the children
that are involved in the flame war
to stop it. the other way is to take
whatever the conflict is
and turn it into a
face to face meeting.
great advice. I knew you guys would come through
and you did,
and we really appreciate it.
so that's three of the questions answered.
thank you very much,
and keep an eye on
the high adventure section
of the site and you will see
some suggestions coming through
for high adventure
in the central part of the united states.
well, thanks for listening once again,
and here's how to keep in touch.
you can read the scoutmaster blog
at scoutmastercgcom
and when you're there,
why don't you subscribe to the
scoutmaster newsletter,
which is a monthly digest of the
scoutmaster blog and podcast,
with some great scouting resources
around a monthly theme.
every newsletter includes a giveaway
from one of our affiliate sponsors.
you.
you can subscribe to the scoutmaster
podcast on itunes and, when you do,
feel free to leave a comment or review
or rating. you can follow
us at scoutmaster blog on facebook
and scoutmastercg
on twitter,
and you can also email me
clarkgreen
with your comments and questions
at scoutmastercg.
cg
at Verizonnet.
that's scoutmastercg
I also want to invite you to take part
in the scoutmaster podcast.
by doing this,
use any phone and call
484-734-0002.
you'll hear a
recorded announcement from me
and then you can record a voicemail
that will be included
in the next scoutmaster podcast.
it might be a question, a comment,
a funny story,
you can sing me a song,
but you can join in
and be part of the scoutmaster
podcast that way.
that's 484-734-0002.
let me take a moment
to remind you:
the scoutmaster blog
and the scoutmaster podcast
are not official publications
of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they endorsed or sponsored
by the Boy Scouts of America.
no, no, no, it's just me with a microphone
trying to lend a hand to scoutleaders
and perhaps have a little bit of fun along the way.
now, before we go,
let's hear from the founder,
Sir Robert,
good luck to you and good camping.
well, thank you, sir,
until next time.